Is there a place in Ukraine where you
can relax every minute, a place where you don't waste time
on things that don't bring you pleasure? Yes, this is
my city, this is Skadovsk, a city of seas, seas,
sun, clean air, fresh fruits,
healing mud.
century, and
Herodotus and other respected ancient
historians will say that everything began here with
Dzharylgach Yahilyas, who formed the island
by catching up with the Briseis branka. And she
fled under her magical
hooves, breaking out the golden sand
every year at the end of spring.
from children's
laughter
summer SKA city from teenage photos where we are
tanned happy so small and so
grown up at the same time city of summer camps
first love first kisses dances
professional and just from the heart
city of sports here you have champions in
beach sports and bodybuilders and
swimmers And also jazzmen who give  concerts
just above the sea  and the singing talents of the
Black Sea Games, what is there to
eat besides the talents? And what about the
festival of roasted Black Sea bull. Autumn, tourists leave their camps, fall asleep.
gather young people in the house of bright
ideas and plan a new season,
and in winter the city slows down to calmness
so that lilac blossoms on the embankment in the
spring, but this year Skadovsk did not
wake up.  the
authorities
bring them to shoot propaganda
stories and show how well we
live now, supposedly freed, they
teach us their version of history
in the darkness of such a long night, we
listen to the rumblings from the right bank of
the Dnieper and prepare to wake up to
meet our own as always, to run and swim again
go to the springs, greet
dolphins, hug family
friends, and finally rest and hear children's
laughter and jazz over the sea and say
Come to us in Skadovsk
because Skadovsk is Ukraine
[music]